it's worse than you realize from cnn of
all places
white house is reviewing section 230
amid efforts to push social media giants
to crack down on misinformation
for those that aren't familiar section
230 is a beautiful law that allows us
the ability to to use social media
platforms without that platform being
sued for what we say
on its surface makes a lot of sense if i
post something on twitter under my name
y'all shouldn't be able to sue twitter
for it this law makes a distinction
however the law also grants the ability
of these platforms to moderate at their
hearts
to their hearts content in which case
they effectively
create an editorial system by which they
can say
we're not banning conservatives it's
just our rules
so they monopolize public discourse they
then start purging conservatives it
creates massive hyperpolarization it
just keeps getting worse
and then we find ourselves here joe
biden wants to get rid of section 230.
donald trump and many conservatives have
been saying get rid of section 230 not
realizing
the law just needs a little bit of
reform the democrats want to get rid of
it
because they want to be able to force
facebook to ban whatever they want
you get rid of section 230 facebook
becomes liable
for all of the for whatever is said
that's wrong for defamation
for even potential criminal uh um uh
negligent
negligence so i'll put it this way i
like to say hey don't take medical
advice from me talk to your doctor why i
don't want you to sue me
some some moron's gonna do something
dumb and then blame me for it i'm not
gonna tell you to do anything
you get people like you know ben shapiro
even it's time to get vaccinated i'm not
gonna do that
i'm gonna say go talk to your doctor
because what if someone says hey tim
poole said to get vaccinated i went to a
bar and i was drunk and i got vaccinated
but i was allergic to it nah
i'm not doing that joe biden wants to be
able to ban whoever
they're going to take away this law and
that's it that's the end of the internet
i will tell you the one of the most
important things that is keeping
right-wing populists and conservatives
in the culture war is the ability to
speak on these platforms they are trying
to take that away by any means necessary
now the problem is many of these people
on the left can't just outright
ban you they can't just delete timpool
and every day
timcast.com is growing and and we're
adding more writers and we're doing more
news
hey that's a bad thing if you're trying
to culturally homogenize around
this you know cult ideology of critical
race theory
the problem is they need a reason to ban
people and they have to do it slowly
if you do too much you shock everybody
the frog's got to be blown in the pot
if they get rid of section 230 they can
just say it's what trump wanted
it's what republicans wanted and that's
it gone
i think the only the only way that it
would make sense it would be to if you
got rid of 230
would reduce twitter to like a public
carrier in which case it could not
ban people but that's an entirely
different argument uh it's
you can read guys like josh hammer who's
very much a conservative
in uh maybe more more of a traditional
sense than i am
and he's uh he's kind of suggested this
common carry would basically make
twitter into like public transit system
um so but this is but you're right
though as far as
the democratic party is concerned as far
as the bi demonstration is concerned
this is what they see as a pathway to
pushing people like us off of these
these channels i think that's right
it will it will bring us back to the era
of
a small handful of channels and it's
already been happening so one of the
things that um
youtube has been trying to do
specifically there was a great purge
that happened i think it was last year
the year before maybe the year before
where they they deleted like millions of
accounts
that were too small banned them from the
partner program
they kicked him out of the partner
program and what this did
was it created a an advertising pool
that was very
much more homogeneous you know you had a
lot of channels that made money off flat
earth stuff and so youtube said we're
getting rid of all of that stuff
some of it was really dumb some of it
was really bad and i know people who
believe stupid things from watching dumb
videos
but you know individual responsibility
right what's happening is youtube
is slowly banning more and more channels
i hear about it every day channels
getting demonetized and getting banned
eventually they're trying to get us to
the point where there's only maybe a few
hundred channels
and all of their opinions are in
alignment for the most part you got your
approved right wing opinion and your
approved left-wing position and of
course
it's all moving towards the left faster
and faster so you know in 10 20 years
potentially the right wing opinion will
be a leftist opinion today
many have made that joke that's that's
what that's what they're able to do
because of the lacks rules of section
230 they can effectively editorialize
the same way
new york times will making money off the
content and then assuming no
responsibility for it
youtube did something interesting a
while back they changed their pay
structure to be
royalties and i think the reason they
did that was because of the potential
argument
that you could say no youtube
is effectively employing these people
there was there was you know attempt to
unionize this happened in i think europe
youtube
unionization there were many on the left
trying to argue that youtubers were no
different than uber drivers
they were de facto employees who
deserved rights then all of a sudden
youtube says now we're paying you
royalties for your content
that way well now you can't argue that
youtube is publishing the content
you can't argue that youtube's employing
these people and once again youtube is
now able to editorialize
and manipulate people and the creepiest
thing about it is
there's a small handful of people on top
of these companies they're as dumb as a
box of rocks
they might be good at selling software
or programming but they do not have the
cognitive faculties required to govern
billions of people ultimate problem is
that those people change
you know larry and sergey bail susan
wojcicki didn't exist
in this arena 10 years ago 12 years ago
and chad hurley built youtube
before google bought it and then changed
the ownership again
jeff bezos just left amazon he just
stepped down
jack dorsey owns like five percent of
twitter he doesn't run that company
anymore he doesn't it's
he's a figurehead yeah they use him to
absorb the criticism while someone else
is which
it's basically a different company but
it has the same name
i think that should be illegal i think
in the future
when a company gets sold it should have
to change its name
it used to be that corporations were
temporary i'm pretty sure corporations
formed for the express purpose of a
mission and they finished it and they
broke apart
but i'm not entirely sure i mean
companies kind of existed because people
with power had access to resources and
if you did then you could grant that to
somebody and so somebody would agree to
follow you and then
i think what was the rules of it was the
brooklyn bridge the first corporation it
could be wrong
maybe i don't know yeah i think we need
some sort of like
specific law that or organizes only
around social media
um and i'm i've been like waiting for
someone to do it
and then joe biden becomes president and
he's not the guy
and like i'm will chamberlain he's the
guy like people like will
like we need to organize some sort of
maybe we have to be the ones just to get
creative and kind of like how do you
make
how do you make a law do you just have
fun do you just like think about
like write a bunch of stuff down and if
everybody likes it then you propose it
to the senate
i was definitely wrong about the
brooklyn bridge by the way who's the
first corporation no there was just tons
of small
corporations by special legislation yeah
so i'm i'm you know part of working i
co-founded mines are you familiar with
mines.com
it's great and we we're working with
like the manila principles which is kind
of like an internet
constitution for the 21st century about
like free how you can like
keep people free on the internet and you
know i'm sitting here looking like an
idiot because i don't have all the i
don't know
i don't know how what the law should be
i mean if we just
uh reformed section 230 a little bit to
say that um
they could only ban speech that was
deemed to be
unlawful for that court or actually they
should just be called common carriers it
shouldn't be incumbent upon
the company at all it should literally
be an act of
uh law that removes the content so
social media network gets x amount of
users per day
becomes a common carrier yes and then it
would be like this you post something
and then on facebook and then people
flag it they flag it to law enforcement
law enforcement then comes in and says
okay we believe
this is a you know incitement or a
threat or whatever
there's risks there and you know i've
been a little i i used to be
more just like look there's incitement
is unlawful speech
obviously we don't agree with that and
there are some things you shouldn't say
like instructing someone how to commit a
crime and stuff like that
the challenge with that i suppose is the
slippery slope of
if unlawful speech can be banned then
the government need only declare some
speech to be unlawful right
so they can say well look you know hate
speech is not
free speech they've been saying that for
a long time so they pass a law saying
hate speech is not protected anymore
and so no you quite literally can't have
a law supersede the constitution
in which case that makes a very serious
conundrum about laws that are like
incitement or direction because
how can those laws be uh you know
affecting the first amendment well to
put it simply supreme court
precedence is what gave us our
understanding of free speech and it
seems like actually free speech
has been improving so there are some
questions and challenges there
ultimately i'll put it this way i still
think it's a good idea it can only be
banned by an act of law enforcement by a
court
the judges should decide if it violates
some kind of you know law or is not in
the spirit of free speech or something
should be uh i guess up to the judges to
figure out in the way you send the
even with those problems send the post
to quarantine until it's decided like is
it
nope so if so say something gets posted
that is illegal it seems
very illegal you flag it you have to you
have to get a warrant
but then if it stays up while you're
investigating it that's a problem no no
it's not they have to get a warrant
and if it's like posting someone's
address and private information when you
know they're at risk
they can get a rushed warrant they do
these things all the time but how long
is that going to take
days few hours even that's a long time
for something to sit up in public view
on the internet because that will get
copied and pasted and like when you find
illegal content like for minds for
instance it was
immediately removed and then sent to the
fbi or whatever
but there's no there's no leaving it up
you can't do that because then it's just
you're you're culpable for inciting
these you know
admittedly i guess we're dealing with a
different arena outside of just the
normal confines of speech
we're talking about people posting
photos photos and videos
and you know in that instance
yeah like if someone posted a video of a
crime taking place
you know of themselves committing a
crime then there needs to be the
discretion for someone with immediate
access
to take that down or at least quarantine
it somehow
the challenge then is you'll get people
in these companies being like
that's hate speech removed and then when
you're like you're not allowed to do
that to go it was an
accident and then it comes back a week
later when no one cares anymore
how you solve for that i do not know how
to remove the human from the uh
process it's it shouldn't be like it
shouldn't be a trust there should be no
trust i
i promise i think it should be um
it should probably be a warrant issue um
i mean yeah you you talk about a lot of
things you've seen when you were when
you were
moderating minds imagine if someone took
a picture that you like one of the most
disgusting pictures don't say what it is
on minds and they put it up on their
window at their house
yeah they go to jail for a lot of this
stuff so if somebody wants to post this
stuff on mines
there should be a warrant an
investigation and
you know action taken but it would have
to happen immediately
i suppose you can say that if someone
put something up on their window that
was uh
objectionable like to an extreme degree
the cops would come and immediately
arrest the person and take it down as
the crime is visible
but sometimes someone will put something
up on someone else's window
and you're like well we're not so it's
not about busting
like um somewhere like hack into your
account uh
well anonymous accounts for instance
like mines doesn't track
people it's anonymous so you don't know
you can't go after the individual you
just have to go after the content
i think that's the way social media
should function in general i don't like
going after individuals you just ban the
channel
if that person wants to start criminal
if it's criminal
and you find out who does it then they
have to face the penalty of law right
but i don't think that you should target
like if someone does something that
violates a term on youtube
you ban the channel that the term was
violated on you don't block that or the
constant from
or the content yeah you get rid of the
content itself and allow the person to
in my opinion form another channel and
if they don't ban if they don't violate
the content again then they're good to
go
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you